[Music]
on this Tuesday night the latest
explanation of three of those flying
objects there's no need to panic the
White House now says they may have been
harmless how the prime minister is
responding and the difficulty recovering
them as rescues become more rare in
Turkey
concerns mount for the health of the
people left homeless much needed
remedies for Canada's ailing Health Care
System it truly is a crisis Atlantic
Canada's Innovative prescriptions and
the state Funeral for a firecracker
mayor she was always always right
honoring the incomparable Hurricane
Hazel mccallion
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with the latest information
emerging about the three objects shot
from the sky over Canadian and American
airspace by American fighter jets we
still don't know what they were and now
the White House says the leading
explanation is they may have been
harmless and had nothing to do with
Espionage or intelligence gathering
these could be tied to commercial or
research entities and benign parts of
the first object that was spotted the
one that was identified as a Chinese spy
balloon have been recovered after it was
shot down off the coast of South
Carolina U.S authorities say it carried
equipment that was clearly for
intelligence surveillance the other
three mystery objects said to be
different in size and shapes still
haven't been recovered and no photos of
them have been released the White House
says they were shot down out of an
abundance of caution but if they really
were harmless was shooting them down and
overreaction Mackenzie gray has our top
story tonight
it's the biggest recovery yet key
Electronics from the Chinese spy balloon
including up to 12 meters of the antenna
found off the coast of South Carolina we
know that our defense and intelligence
departments are analyzing every piece of
this any debris from the other suspected
balloons thought to be the size of a car
shot down over Lake Huron Alaska and
Yukon yet to be recovered but the search
for the debris facing deep water and
frigid temperatures we have deployed a
number of aircraft
to assist in that recovery effort I want
to indicate that the terrain is
extremely rugged it is extremely remote
the Lake Huron shoot down required two
missiles from a U.S fighter jet on the
fourth one over Lake Huron first shot
missed a second shot hit in this case
the missiles land or the missile landed
harmlessly in the Water of Lake Huron
the origins for the three UFOs starting
to become more clear the White House
saying their likely commercial objects
that did not come from a foreign
government or a spy agency there's
strong consideration that these objects
are indeed benign Americans believe the
balloon the Prime Minister non-committal
on if he agrees with the American
assessment there's a range of different
balloons who that seem to be in
different sizes and different different
numbers
former head of ceases believes it's
premature to take any explanation off
the table if it's too early for us to
say it's military it's also too early
for us to say it's civilian we either
know or we don't know so I think we need
to keep all of our options open NORAD
announced this afternoon that it turned
its attention away from balloons and
back onto what it traditionally does
Donna when on Monday they intercepted
Russian fighter jets and bombers off the
coast of Alaska
okay Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks
Canada's foreign affairs minister was in
Ukraine today Melanie Jolie met with the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
as he pushes for more support for his
country's fight against Russia
in a statement zielinski said the two
discussed further security and defense
cooperation and that Canada's support of
the Ukrainian Army is invaluable while
that meeting was happening NATO defense
ministers gathered in Brussels the head
of NATO says almost one year since the
full-scale invasion of Ukraine there are
no signs Russian President Vladimir
Putin is preparing for peace on the
contrary and as Crystal gemancing
Reports NATO members are being asked to
ramp up production of ammunition and
military equipment
what's that
you see Ukraine's defense minister
shared something close to his heart with
the cameras his country's wish for
fighter jets a light moment in a
high-stakes high-profile Gathering of
allies but Kremlin is still betting that
it can wait us out the contact group a
side event for defense ministers meeting
in Brussels where allies listened to
what Ukraine needs to battle against
invading Russian forces and decide what
can be provided donations the Kremlin
says are dragging out the conflict and
raising the possibility of further
escalation NATO and its Partners however
say support for Ukraine will not stop it
is important from a Canadian perspective
to continually put on the table any Aid
we possibly have
Germany which allowed countries
including Canada to send leopard to
tanks is also coming to the table with
more it signed a contract to restart
production of ammunition for the gephard
anti-aircraft guns ensuring it could
keep supplying Ukraine ammunition
supplies in general are a critical need
in this war
in Ukraine there's heavy shelling along
the front line in the East part of a
brutal Russian campaign that has seen
invading forces gaining ground around
bekmoot
this Ukrainian Soldier says Russian
Artillery and mortar attacks have
increased from one to nearly 10 a day
American experts say talk of Russia
launching a new Massive Attack using
fighter jets appears to just be talk but
some kind of spring offensive is
anticipated U.S army General Mark milley
however outright dismisses Russia Russia
has lost
they've lost strategically
operationally and tactically but Russia
is still pushing ahead forcing Ukraine
to keep fighting crystal commencing
Global News London
Ukraine's neighbor Moldova closed its
airspace at one point today and
scrambled fighter jets after a
balloon-like object was spotted near its
border with Ukraine once authorities
determined there was no threat air
traffic resumed Moldova has repeatedly
accused Russia of plotting to
destabilize the former Soviet Republic
the president Maya Sandu claims Moscow
has plans to use foreign saboteurs with
military background to overthrow her
pro-european government and last week
Vladimir zielinski said Kiev had
intercepted Plans by Russian Security
Services to destroy Moldova the Kremlin
rejects the accusations
in turkey and Syria the heartache
continues and the death toll keeps
Rising more than 40 thousand people are
now known to have died in the
earthquakes and after more than a week
finding survivors is increasingly rare
it is the dead that are being recovered
in Turkey the body of a Canadian woman
has been found Samar Zora was found
under the rubble of a five-story
building in the city of antakia the 33
year old PhD candidate had traveled to
the city for her research in
anthropology
the next phase is recovery and relief
though as Mike Armstrong reports all
hope is not lost
foreign
[Music]
stretched into more than a week and
somehow survivors are still being found
this was a man and woman pulled out of a
building by Rescuers Tuesday evening
earlier it was two women pulled from
another building but after more than 200
hours trapped they are alive but barely
the celebrations are more and more
subdued and they are fewer and fewer
according to reports there were only
seven rescues on this day in a country
where tens of thousands are still
missing
the Survivor spent his day outside the
collapsed building where his niece lived
with her seven roommates he says he's
checked hospitals and Crews have gone
through the debris
not a trace has been found he says
there's absolutely no news searches are
being called off in some areas as hope
Fades rescue efforts now turn to
recovery according to the World Health
Organization one million people in
Turkey have been left homeless and
infrastructured damage affects Millions
more many don't have access to clean
water or sanitation it's a great concern
and it increases the risk of waterborne
diseases
thank you
crews are bringing down dangerous
buildings it's a delicate process as is
organizing disaster relief team Rubicon
a veteran-led disaster relief group has
a small team on the ground preparing for
a larger deployment but it says too many
groups arriving too early can be a
problem the World Health Organization
and the Turkish Ministry of Health and
their government will determine when we
deploy what we deploy to do and where
we'll go tent cities are being built but
many are still in the streets this
family is living in front of their
damaged home
the mother says her children cry every
day and she tries to be strong for them
the Turkish government says about 42
thousand buildings collapsed or are in
urgent need of demolition region is also
dealing with a mass Exodus more than 150
000 people have left Southern turkey
with more following this man says he's
moving West and starting from zero he
says he wouldn't wish what he's going
through on anyone like Armstrong Global
News
in Syria more Aid is now getting through
after two more Crossing points were
opened up on the border with turkey 11
relief trucks used one of those new
routes today carrying blankets Jerry
cans and mattresses the U.N now says
nearly 9 million people in Syria have
been affected by last week's earthquakes
more than 7 400 buildings in that
country are completely or partially
destroyed the U.N has launched a 397
million dollar funding appeal for Syria
calling it one of the worst disasters in
recent memory
the human suffering from this epic
natural disaster should not be made even
worse by man-made obstacles excess
funding supplies
Aid must get through from all sides to
all sides through all routes without any
restrictions
the U.N says the funding would benefit
nearly 5 million people with the most
urgent humanitarian needs over the next
three months
New Zealand has declared a state of
emergency after Cyclone Gabrielle swept
through the Northern parts of that
country
more rain fall 24-hour period the New
Zealand usually gets in the entire month
of February landslides and floods have
blocked major roads Fallen trees of
smashed houses more than 200 thousand
people are without power the military is
now helping with evacuations and the
distribution of essential supplies in
the hardest hit areas
the derailment of a train in Ohio on
February 3rd still has residents that
are concerned about the Hazardous and
toxic chemicals it was carrying people
in East Palestine Ohio have been told
they don't need to be concerned about
air quality about 50 of the 150 train
cars went off the tracks a number of
them were carrying toxic and
carcinogenic chemicals they caught fire
and burned for days evacuation orders
were issued to about 5 000 people and
controlled detonations were done to
release the chemicals but concerned
residents raised questions about
lingering smells dead fish and chickens
plus possible long-term health effects
in a press conference today Ohio
officials said air quality tests showed
readings below safe levels
the first Republican to challenge Donald
Trump for the nomination of the
Republican party has made it official
Nikki Haley the former South Carolina
governor and American ambassador to the
UN announced her plans to seek the
nomination for the 2024 presidential
election
Republicans have lost a popular vote in
seven out of the last eight presidential
elections that has to change
Haley had said she would not challenge
Trump for the Republican nomination she
now says it's time for a generational
change she says what she calls the need
for fiscal responsibility prompted her
to run if she wins the nomination and
gets elected she would be the first
woman president and the first American
President of Indian Heritage
they are Innovative and badly needed
treatments coming up what's being done
in Atlantic Canada to help solve the
health care crisis
[Music]
we report so often on the gaps and the
problems in Canada's Health Care System
but there are efforts underway to make
improvements Ross Lord reports on some
of the Innovations in Atlantic Canada
that are already making a difference for
patients
as Healthcare outcomes become more
tragic more often finding ways to
improve the system has become a
desperate Pursuit it truly is a crisis
you know people really are struggling to
receive care as a patient some
Innovations are coming from Atlantic
Canada where an older population creates
more urgency for change
Newfoundland Labrador has started flying
cardiac patients from remote regions
into St John's for some procedures then
back to their home communities on the
same day by doing that we avoided the
requirement for a bid and these days
beds in hospitals are more precious than
gold Newfoundland Health leaders say
their program is a first in Canada it
puts Patients First
patients and their families it brings
care to them kind of on their own terms
quicker without waiting around the
hospital bed being transported here and
stuck in hospital for days as other
strategies emerge like Ontario expanding
more private delivery of Public Health
Care there are efforts to streamline the
disjointed flow of information sometimes
when I'm seeing the patient in front of
me I
got to the most recent visit
real-time data Alicia Hawker is the
president of doctors Nova Scotia she
applauds the province's announcement it
will spend 365 million dollars over 10
years to establish a single digital
information card on each patient every
doctor and every Allied Health
professional will have access to
real-time data that will be accurate and
it'll just be so much more streamlined
that uh Physicians and nurses will be
able to focus more on the patients Nova
Scotia is catching up to provinces that
already use real-time data but
supporters say when it's up and running
in a couple of years the system will
help heal fractures in a system where
there's less margin for error than ever
before
Ross Lord Global News Halifax cutting
costs ahead how Rising food prices are
forcing families to be more frugal
foreign
Just a Touch not as much as many
economists had predicted new numbers
released today by the U.S Bureau of
Labor Statistics show inflation came
down to 6.4 percent from 6.5 percent in
December the cost of living went up by
0.5 percent as the price of food gas and
shelter continue to rise the Slowdown
came largely from one sector of the
Consumer Price Index used cars the price
of used vehicles was soaring at this
time last year and is now down by almost
12 percent year over year here at home a
new report has found one in five
children in Manitoba are living in
poverty that is the highest rate of any
province in Canada the reports authors
say the increasing cost of food and
higher interest rates mean more families
are struggling especially indigenous
families Melissa Ridge and traveled to a
remote Manitoba First Nation where those
ballooning prices are forcing families
to make hard decisions
this is like me for the month starts at
1800 while many across the country are
making tough choices to stretch dollars
I'm happy that's only once a month
because if it's every two weeks like my
truck payment I would probably be crying
Chantal green survives with more money
going out than coming in
foreign
she manages her band's Car Wash and
laundromat getting around here means a
truck is a necessity
and an expensive one
going down with my gas tank now it's
really a struggle
anywhere from like a quarter tank to
half a tank it cost me from 50 to 100
don't forget your shopping bag let's go
get some coffee creamer
do you think we need anything else
Fisher River Cree Nation and nearby
paguas First Nation have two main
grocery stores to choose from they're
three hours from the convenience of
shopping around for sales like many in
the cities get to do staff at one of the
groceries says that he feels awful every
time he puts out ever increasing price
stickers knowing that so many are
struggling this is typically what my
freezer looks like the only reason this
bottom half is filled is because we
received a meat pack from our band this
Christmas for green the struggle is that
feeding her daughter means not feeding
herself with the two adults in the house
we made the sacrifice thing okay we can
sacrifice Mead we could sacrifice milk
there you go sacrifices she feels have
taken a toll on their health I
definitely think so because my dad is a
renal cancer patient who is also a
diabetic my diet is horrible I pretty
much eat canned like stuff out of canned
foods or stuff you'd find in the freezer
section the fruits I buy and vegetables
I try to make sure I get them into my
dad
the only way she can get protein and
vegetables into Shantae is this certain
name brand soup with Rising costs and no
end in sight she focuses on the positive
that her situation isn't as bad as some
I've been preparing for this my whole
life kind of in a way could I get that
you see
Melissa ridgen Global News Fisher River
Cree Nation
remembering Hurricane Hazel next
celebrating the life of one of Canada's
most memorable mayors
[Music]
how do you say goodbye to a woman who is
larger than life and served in public
life for decades well Hazel mccallion
was honored with a state funeral today
on what would have been her 102nd
birthday she knew so many people touched
so many lives and was known as The
Matriarch of Mississauga as Mike droulet
reports they turned out today to say
farewell
[Music]
anybody who ever met Hazel mccallion for
more than a minute knows she wouldn't
want a somber State funeral after all
we're talking about Hurricane Hazel it's
a big fish looks like a shark who in her
90s had to be held down by the late Rob
Ford so the fish she was reeling in
wouldn't pull her overboard and what a
fish that was the people of Mississauga
have spoken tonight it was clear from
that day in 1978 Mississauga had elected
a firecracker as mayor someone who would
transformed the cow pastures of suburban
Toronto into the seventh largest city in
Canada Hazel never hesitated to say what
was on her mind not for a second
and she was always always right
she faced adversity early on when a
trained derailment in subsequent
chemical fire forced the evacuation of
two hundred thousand of her constituents
her leadership during that crisis
cemented her tough reputation and could
have opened doors to provincial or
federal politics if she had been
interested prime minister Justin Trudeau
joked she would have bristled at
following party orders my father and I
weren't the only Prime Ministers to
wonder how
great but challenging she might have
been as a minister
before realizing it was most likely a
bit of a moot point we probably would
have ended up as ministers serving in
her cabinet even until the very end she
was a force of nature
former prime minister Jean Creations
says he never thought he would retire
before Hazel and we kind of agreed that
we should leave together so when I quit
that 70 she called me to give me hell
what happened to you
as easily compared to you I'm a chicken
so I'm gone
she was small yet Mighty she outlasted
her contemporaries and politics and
those who followed as well today would
have been her 102nd birthday it's
somewhat surprising she's not still here
Global News Toronto
and we leave you tonight with some
moments from Hazel mccallion's time as
mayor a Trailblazer for women in
politics who left her mark on
Mississauga and across the country that
is global national for this Tuesday
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you